hey everyone how's it going my name is
miyuko and welcome back to my channel
where we talk about
tech career and life all right everybody
today
we're going to talk about whether you
should negotiate your salary
so i know that i haven't really talked
about salary or like
money compensation things really at all
on this channel
but recently i met someone who is an
expert in this i met my friend sarah who
is the lead negotiator at levels.fyi
she's also a former tech recruiter at
amazon facebook and google so
she knows like salary negotiation stuff
really really well i had an incredibly
enlightening chat with her
and so i brought her onto my show muko's
corner to share her advice
so today in this video i'm going to
share what she said about whether you
should negotiate your salary
whether you're coming in as an intern to
a company you're an early career
software engineer or your mid-career
so let's dive in so let's get the
elephant out of the room because we're
here to talk about negotiations
specifically like once you get an offer
from them
they give you the first packet and you
see your first number and all of your
rsus and all of that kind of stuff
um i think the biggest burning question
that everybody has
is should you negotiate your salary
a hundred percent yes so a lot of
companies
they have uh recently restructured their
compensation or even the negotiation
process so typically they
always arrange for compensation um
and typically within that range they
break it up into
like three tier um so minimum mid
and then max um for a lot of the time
too for a recruiter because the range is
so large from like the minimum to like
the max
number typically the range can be
anywhere from
you know 20k difference all the way to
like 100 to 200k difference
and this is why a lot of the times too
the recruiter will try to ask you like
hey what are you looking for
in terms of compensation so they can
gauge like where can they land you
within that range
and if um and typically two even when
you show a number
they typically will still try how to
start you out either at like the minimum
number or in between the minimum
and the mid number nobody will ever like
automatically give you the max number
and it's just my company's policy too
but we have to start everyone out with
the same number and we would wait for
you to ask
i'm not happy with this number can we do
something about this
that's pretty much applied for you know
any company that's more mature
like there's defunding or higher as well
as buying republic companies
now sometimes for startup companies um
the range tend to be a little bit
smaller
um but in term of face salary you're
going to see that number pretty
consistent even for smaller companies
versus like
companies and so i guess like now let's
break it down into
parts of your career so there's i think
kind of
three very distinct periods of your
career one in which
you're trying to get an internship as a
college student or
otherwise you're kind of trying to get
your foot into the door into the tech
industry
and then the other step is kind of like
your first
role in tech um even within that there's
like college recruiting so you're
going directly from university into
the tech industry or those who come from
boot camps and other backgrounds and get
their first job
and then there's also the mid-career
folks who are also getting offers for
salaries as well
so i guess how would you navigate all of
those three different
um parts of your career in negotiating
your salary
yeah so good questions um so far in turn
it
is a little bit trickier to negotiate
because campus recruiting is very much
so different than industry recruiting
and for campus recruiting
typically for an intern you're gonna get
paid hourly
and um it's not as flexible in terms of
negotiating there so let's say for
example
if they start you out with 80 an hour
you can
push for a little bit higher at 85
dollars an hour but the range wouldn't
be
like 100k to 200k or anything like that
um for a few companies um they will
actually offer equity to the intern as
well so the equity component
is something that's more flexible but
for companies that don't offer equity
for internship it's harder to
to push the the salary compensation
there
however if you get a returning offer for
your next internship with the same
company
because you already have you know the
relationship with your manager
the team already know you there is a
track of record about your performance
that would be the best time for you to
renegotiate your hourly rate when you
return to that
internship now for newgrad new brand is
a little bit different so for newgrad we
treat them
as an industry and recruiting track too
so we pay them just like
similar to any full-time position where
the package would be
um you know they we would have base
equity
sign-on bonus and performance bonus and
so the first
offer tend to be a little bit tricky and
i feel like a lot of the new grad
kind of get really nervous about
negotiating because they feel like
man if i ask for more money a i might
you know i'm scared that if i don't
performs at this level
they might you know i might get fired or
or if i negotiate for too much i might
lose this offer
um i'll tell you right now you're not
gonna lose your offer because you
negotiate
um so typically like i said the
recruiter always lands you
in like the minimum between like either
the minimum number or in between the
minimum and the mid number
there's still always room to go so if
you push back a little bit more
giving them the reason why so that's
another thing that i want to mention
here too
is as a recruiter sometimes certain
things are out of my control
i'm the middleman and there's a protocol
that i have to follow
and i can't just give you a number just
because you asked for it like i need
some
information or reasons behind it so if
you have
any competing offers you don't have to
share the details of the competing
offers
but just knowing that they are there
would help the case
and then why what are your concerns
about this salary number for example if
base is too low
or because you're moving and you need
additional like sign on bonus to help
with the move for example
so not only that you need to ask for a
number or know the number that you need
to ask for but also be prepared to
provide some reasons as well
same with mid-level um someone who you
know may be
going from junior level to a mid-level
position
the negotiation process is going to be
pretty similar
except for new grad the range tend to be
a little bit narrower
and for folks that are mid-level the
range can tend to be a little bit larger
and so just to demonstrate a little bit
more uh for example the minimum
for a new grad to the maximum number
would be like 50k
difference and for folks that are
mid-level it would be anywhere from 20k
upward to 80k and 100k difference from
like the minimum to the max number there
all right everybody thank you all so
much for watching the video i hope you
liked it
sarah shared like so many incredible
insights about salary and negotiation
so if you'd like to watch the video
recording of that episode of minku's
corner then you can become a member
today on youtube to get full access
you'll also be able to listen to the
audio recording of the show through the
podcast version of mooco's corner
i also wanted to take a moment to thank
the sponsor of today's video
brilliant so i think an important part
about negotiating your salary
as a software engineer is to really kind
of continue to build on your existing
skills
in computer science and stem to provide
more value to a company
and if y'all have programmed before you
know that practicing problems
is a much more effective way to learn
than watching lectures which is why
i love brilliant brilliant is a
problem-solving based website and app
with a hands-on approach
with over 60 interactive courses in math
science and computer science
they all have an element of storytelling
code writing
interactive challenges and problem
solving is part of their courses
you can use brilliant to get into the
habit of learning new things
every day like maybe you want to do a
pomodoro timer of one brilliant course a
few times a week
or dedicate saturday mornings to learn
something new so maybe as part of that
habit you learn more about how
cryptography actually works
or you brush up on your stats knowledge
to better make sense of the data that's
out there
so make sure to check out brilliant
today by going to brilliant.org
hello myuco where the first 200 people
will get 20
off the annual premium subscription
thank you again to brilliant for
sponsoring and thank you so much for
watching and i will see you next time
bye